all right
hi everyone so for people joining this
live stream
we are having a discussion about how
well from language code should be
rendered when it is
exported in a variety of different
formats
so that we appropriately preserve or not
the beautiful formatting we make the
code fit in better
to uh the look of things like academic
papers and so on
okay so i think is this
is this basically my notebook from
before
it's rearranged a bit but yes
it is almost entirely your content
okay well maybe i should just um
uh save this where was it
where where did i have it do you know
what where is it it was in your
ielty folder sure
okay where oh just as i can see when i
have to check
one second
code formatting probably uh yes that was
thumbs up
okay all right okay so if you looked at
code formatting o3 you'd see
pretty much this content but in a
modestly different sequence
okay okay here we go
all right so let's talk about what we're
trying to do here
so um
well i think these are the you know the
question is what should this look like
right well or or you know is this
you know are these the best workflows i
mean you know how do you
go from authoring to well whatever
your final target is right so i mean
technical publishing
is it okay so i think
this is okay so what are the
um okay code publishing workflows
right okay so so then i want to add here
you know um uh
educational material
about uh about
code right that's another case where you
really want the code
to be seen where you want yeah here we
go this is
it's this case the code is the main
story
that's another the code is the main
story type thing
okay another one is is um
code we focused a lot last time on
academic papers i didn't know
if there should be other sorts of
publishing well right
so let's let's look at the discussion as
well what the target
i mean targeted users okay um
well here it is i mean this is the
answer we already talked about this
books websites blogs github no
you know notebooks
right
okay so
i mean there's also the question of
things like tech form
and what they should do and how they
should relate to this
am i making sense
and copy as tech is basically using tech
form
i understand that i understand that
although it's not evaluating
yeah um okay well i mean these are the
basic things we need i mean
the question of what the workflow looks
like i mean i would have thought
that and this is a ux thing i assume we
have a
path here do we have path here
we don't actually please try to get him
yep uh
right so i mean the ux
um needs to be
you know okay so you say copy as tech
but maybe there are some options there
how do we handle the options did you
understand what i'm saying
i understand what you're saying okay
look you know what we've got a bunch of
people in this meeting
uh wake up guys
is it clear how we handle fonts special
characters
i don't know how you make that
connection yeah well i mean i think we
have a bunch of tech
information in the product like we know
what alpha is called in tech
but there's characters we only support
right there's stuff we've invented
i i don't i'm not even sure off the top
of my head what
happens if you try to do things that
donate don't map the tech
well let's let's see what happens if we
do if we do for example
um let's pick one of our characters like
imaginary eye
okay and let's say a tech form of that
well actually we just have or maybe
maybe better uh
export string of tech um
which might have more stuff around it i
don't know what that does
okay but export string
see the point is the question is how do
we get um an actual imaginary eye
character i mean here it just translated
it to i
do you get what i'm saying yeah that was
pretty lame
so that's a good point um
but in general
my view is that we're going to end up
with
uh sort of options here because for
example do you carry over syntax
coloring do you not
do you try and make something that looks
like i don't know what the term for our
elegant code fonts is going to be
um but uh
um the
do you imagine it all be copy driven you
know or
how do you as opposed to what
as for options i think typically they
end up being export options right
so copy as has a preset
right so to rogers question
i mean one possibility is is you might
have some kind of
automated build process it
you know copy is very human driven
but there might be a non-human-driven
non-interactive way to
to compose some of these materials but
we did start this conversation with
it being copy driven because of the
thinking that people are
writing in tech and just need to grab a
few things from from that so
i think there are two cases there are
you know
the workflows okay so here
what we're dealing with is um overall
well documents uh uh
which documents are are used
are used okay so they're really two
cases
um you know it's a
you know uh external format
is the main format
and its notebooks are the main format
those are the two cases as far as i'm
concerned
so in other words in the in case number
one external format is the main format
it's like uh put you know fragments
okay so there are two cases here one is
interactively
you know insert fragments into a
into an otherwise into an otherwise
complete document
and the other case is uh
build the document
using string template xml template etc
am i making sense and the other one is
notebooks to the main format
and there it it's like uh
um you know want conversion
of all content to an external format
i mean that's independent within a
notebook itself
[Music]
within the notebook or we want or
or we'll publish the notebook we'll
publish as a notebook
okay and then what we're talking about
is the elegant code formatting
right does that make sense to people
yes you understand what i'm saying yeah
i think that that
template exists in the external format
if it's a pdf
right so yeah right so the elegant code
formatting is what we've been discussing
with jeremy
and um you know the thing maybe jeremy
can show the latest version of that
um uh i think
i think it's in this under design
mockups couple sections down
should be there okay okay
um by the way path isn't that in the
meeting
okay good um roger you were saying
something we interrupted you
well i think that we could promote the
template idea a lot more
because i don't think people see that
it's been there for a while but i don't
think people
understand it yeah right the right latex
documents i think most researchers will
do that they will not use notebooks
at least not no no no this is not but
they don't do it programmatically
i mean they'll do this they'll be using
some external
random thing where they're writing a
tech document and
they'll want to paste in a piece of code
i think both
if you write something bigger then you
you know
like a book or textbook or courseware or
you know then
but you're not going to want to
programmatically generate your text
because that's what this is for
this is for something where you're
essentially generating a report
in pdf or whatever else where
you know for example for example i could
you know you know
if i have a textbook project i would you
know that's how i would do it
i i i have to say and you could say i'm
influenced by my background in software
development
but you know the notion of i mean if i'm
writing stuff in tech and i want to
populate stuff i could easily imagine
using
uh what file template essentially you
know
okay all right big publishing projects
have a build system
you know well i always say no certainly
right okay so
and that's makes a lot of sense if you
might change the format and things like
that part way through
um okay fair enough okay let's let's
take a look at jeremy's thing here
which one should we look at jeremy
that's on mute a second png should i
think that's what we want
there's an html version also but this is
the
kind of gray for non kind of for
secondary characters
slightly bigger right so this is the
thing where we imagine
this is kind of the math like formatting
of code
so you know clearly that's one of the
possibilities when you want to put it in
your elegant document
and again that that relates to code is
the main story versus the code is part
of the explanation
versus the no code is scene case
right in the no code is seen case which
is the one i've been doing for blogs in
recent times
one of the big issues there is that
every okay so big issue
is um main issue
every ctc fragment click to copy
fragment
um has to run independently
am i making sense you don't get to set
up state to get them to run
and so that requires this dependency
mechanism or it requires what we're
doing for a lot of
my pieces which is to have a cloud
object
have the first thing in the click to
copy fragment
paste be a cloud object to get
so that makes sense to people when you
say dependency mechanism what do you
mean by
what dependency okay so so here's the
here's what i mean is let's say we've
got documentation and we've got
20 lines of an example okay
and you are clicked to copying line 18.
but in order for line 18 to work lines 1
2 and three have to already been
run right and so we have are you saying
we have a solution for that
i believe that we do have a solution for
that at the level of documentation i
believe the solution is
multi-cellular click to copy which means
that when you
click when you copy you will get putting
multiple cells on the clipboard
and some of those cells are the
initialization cells basically
okay and um i mean i think that's a
reasonable solution
uh the alternative is to burn everything
into a single cell
with you know with semicolons which is i
think what we had been doing
for the things i was writing but it was
quite inelegant because sometimes they
got quite big
the other thing that's very important
which i hope has been solved john
is maintaining iconization through click
to copy
um i'm not remembering off top of my
head but
it's a thing to check yeah and and um
let's make sure we pursue that uh
okay we have a whole bunch of detailed
comments on the
live stream and take a look at a few of
them stephen says
in notebooks code appears to be
autoformatted for vertical parsimony
uh he'd love an option to format code
um where nesting is emphasized well
guess what in version 12.3 we have that
um and i don't know whether we can
and that's in i mean that that's in the
package editor right or
how do i get to that i don't know
exactly what feature you're referring to
i'm referring to brenton's code
formatting oh oh oh oh oh oh okay
uh yes it it definitely is in the
package editor
and i'm not sure it's yet been extended
to things other than the package editor
but in the package editor why is this
taking any time to
start up okay so in the in the format
cell menu of the package editor we are
we have this notion of airiness
and airiness is precisely this what
you're talking about that is are you
why is it the case you know is it the
right decision that the toolbar doesn't
magnify when you magnify the notebook
uh well imagine if you magnified a 300
and then half the notebook is toolbar
i know but but how could could you
magnify the toolbar because
when you're giving a presentation or
something and you want
everything to be bigger on the screen
how do you do that with the toolbox well
most of the time when you're giving
presentations
the toolbar is not the story that's only
an us issue
yeah i know designers don't care about
showing the toolbars we do because it's
our product
well fair enough okay in any case for
steven's comment here
this is exactly what you want this is
this airiness setting
which determines how airy the um
uh the code will be and if you set it to
all the right hand side
it will be very vertically spread out
give it a try let us know what you think
uh sander is commenting annoying thing
constantly have is that utf characters
are not nicely copied but instead copied
as backslash omega etc
like you paste into other software okay
so yes what is that what is the story
with that
so okay the uh um
so the issue there is i mean some things
we're gonna have to copy as long name
because
because they're in the private unicode
space and they don't make
any sense in other applications that
will always be true it will never change
uh other things there's a certain
judgment call i mean
you know we could copy an integral sign
for example
and that would work in many applications
um
but it would also uh
you know it might actually make things
less clear
in a number of cases when you when you
copy and paste um uh
the uh uh you know like the you know
capital alpha versus capital a
you know as a as oh but that's nice look
the main issue is this
when we started doing this in the 1990s
we were one of you know we were one of
the very first companies to adopt
unicode
it was completely implausible that's
something that we
an alpha that we copy out in unicode
will be correctly handled by j random
mail program
yeah okay i think it's worth reassessing
that
because it could be the case now that
essentially every application we want to
interact with now handles unicode in a
reasonable way
well so is so the issue of uh
of the the greeks i would not want to
flip over on the greeks yet because i
know we're changing the way we're doing
greeks
exactly exactly um
uh but uh but i i worry about some cases
in the technical symbols where uh
the you know when you paste into a
random app
the font that it shows might not have a
glyph for that symbol
um well the question is is that really
an issue in the modern world
it it it it sometimes is it really is i
mean you know
you might uh you might have something
where
uh oh you know like uh uh you know uh
chess pieces or something
and you know you copy and paste the
chess piece and it is correctly encoded
in the other application but then it
just shows as in
you know empty glyph
the you might recall that we've had
issues around this with the ipa
uh uh with the ipa characters for
example
where the we actually had to specify
specific fonts for things where we were
showing ipa characters because
uh they didn't show up in kind of
arbitrary fonts
yes well okay so what this is saying is
this is another one of these options
that we need
right so copy the clipboard should have
options and
the question then is if you say copy
paste
you know is there any ux that we can
provide so like let's imagine
and and by the way i should say what we
do right now is
you know uh you know i i have a rough
classification
of you know if it's alphabetic we copy
it as utf-8 so it alphabetic for any
language
um and uh
you know it's a heuristic so there might
be you know some places where the
heuristic slightly fails but it's
generally that's true um but if it's
what i consider technical uh
so you know then then we can again
i get it let me make a suggestion okay
my suggestion would be
if you select and you see that there is
a special character in the selection
then you bring up a raft here which
gives
the options for you know copy
as you know copy with long names
copy uh you know as raw unicode
so in other words most of the time you
wouldn't see that
but if you do a copy you know in in the
case where you're copying where the
destination is another
wolverine language you know environment
right you don't care
but it's okay yes and and that always
works
of course it always works but my point
is that it's not that painful
to see a little tiny raft thing come up
um and uh uh you know maybe it's just a
little
plus i don't know what it would be i
don't know what the iconography would be
um that uh you know maybe the
iconography is as literal as backslash
bracket
blank and then versus blob or something
i don't know what but it's something
where
you know you'd see that every time you
select
something that has special characters in
it and that way we get the option
yeah i mean that's not totally
unreasonable we don't have a mechanism
for selection rafts right now
it is on the roadmap um okay
okay so that will be a solution to that
problem so so the default
would probably be to copy as long names
because it's the one that's always going
to work
except in the cases where you've
described the heuristic i mean so in
other words
in general one could have three settings
there use
use your heuristic about when to copy as
you know
as a verbatim unicode then another one
would be
never copy as verbatim unicode always
copy as verbatim unicode
right yeah okay so i think that's a
decent solution to that problem
steve is talking about another steve
here okay
wait a minute um
let's see exporting 2d to pdf
and svg
wait a minute the question is
so steve is commenting on something to
do with scaling of exporting
um trying to export some 2d and 3d stuff
uh the 2d to pdf
and svg the only way to
scale is to set the size of the export
oh i'm confused by that
um
so wait a minute so this is so what
steve is saying
is
that he wants a mechanism to
be able to specify the literal unity
confused by this well i mean the problem
with the literal units is
it's the famous example of how big
should it be on the screen oh whoops i'm
using a projector
in this giant you know amphitheater
right well but but we do in fact
you know i mean we're using literal
units uh in
uh you know in most places right now
except
what we're using is points uh uh
but i so you know i mean you can
change the image size of a graphic or
something like that and that will be in
points
um but i think that i'm not sure that
that
really addresses okay no i think i think
what would address what steve is saying
i think
is something that actually we should do
which is the very obvious thing
of supporting that why wouldn't we
support that
i'm sorry i was the thing i just typed
image size goes to 10 centimeters oh
yes that's that's that's on the road map
but it's not trivial
um why why don't we just do a conversion
to points
uh because these things uh get passed
around to the front end
you mean but but but at the first level
right you would just do this
the obvious way to do it is to do an
evaluation and evaluate that to points
and the thing that goes in the front end
ends up being something that has points
in it
uh so then you would have to
uh you know have the logic of
you know everything that has an image
size option in the kernel
do that evaluation
it seems unrealistic for you to handle i
mean what if somebody says no
it's entirely realistic for us to handle
it it's just
not how does it look if you say somebody
says 10 to the minus 20 paw sex
are you really going to do the round
trip to find out that unit resolve that
unit
well so uh yeah i mean our plan is to
for for more common units we'll do it
ourselves and for less common units
we'll round trip
and you know if somebody insists on
specifying everything in parsecs then
it's going to take a long time to
resolve these things and they just kind
of got what they asked for but if
they're going to ask for it in
centimeters
or millimeters or something we can
figure that out in the front end we
don't need a round trip for it that
point
that seems sensible to me
and this is absolutely on our to-do list
but it's
i haven't seen that is that on the user
assistance to-do list
uh there's a much longer roadmap than
what we come up with because your
assistance and and
i remember i keep the entire front end
roadmap not just user assistance
yeah i know i realize that um
yeah steve is commenting that things
like notion and overleaf
um are evolving the way that tech should
be used and i agree with that and and
that's an important thing for us to
understand
how to plug into those systems i don't
know if anybody has looked at that
and it might also be a business
discussion with those organizations
to figure that out so who's
manu i think your project managing here
um
somebody just has to look at that i mean
does anybody here know about those
systems enough to be able to comment
uh you know the interesting thing is
that uh
parth and i do uh
you know do stuff with notion but i i
guess i i wasn't familiar with the
uh sorts of things that are being
discussed in the comments so yeah
we've just never done anything with tech
support there so
with tex support there sorry i
realized that was ambiguous right
well we should look at it i mean the
other thing is the
the versions that the sort of the toy
versions of tech
that are used in like wikimedia and
things like this
we should make sure that those are
things we support does anybody know
whether that works right now
does anybody know whether the the subset
of tech
did you understand what i'm saying is is
correctly supported
i understand what you're saying you mean
for import for us
no no no for both ways around oh well
i don't know okay well so we need to
find that out
i mean copy as what is the name of that
that thing that's
copy as quotes tech
for um wiki
i don't know what that's called you know
what i'm talking about right
and it's supported by talking about but
i think they may just refer to it as
tech
uh they may but it isn't in fact tech
it's a subsidy
no i know i no i get it but i i'm not
sure there is a proper name for it
okay or at least not a popular proper
name
fair enough but i mean we can clarify
what that is
yeah but tim okay
uh
sandra is commenting greek letters
infinity will be nice in the copy
we're aware of this the main issue is
that we have been using
italic greek as in the greek language
characters
um for rendering our greek
for the last 30 years and we are going
to change that
to using the math characters the math
greek characters
that were added to unicode as our way of
rendering
math greeks and that will be a good
thing when it comes to actually
rendering greek
because that's been confused for a while
and to be clear that doesn't actually
change what
what we'll show on screen but it will
change the underlying unicode code
points that
that represent those things so the long
names
will map to different code points um
right yeah ali is commenting that
they want am
a faster front end you know it's a very
difficult problem
and you know you can compare what
happens in the
cloud front end with which is a
completely reimplemented different
technology stack
from the desktop front end and they both
have
different kinds of issues so so
so the most common i mean there are
other issues but the most
common uh thing that slows down
scrolling which is mentioned in the
comment uh is that we're making a
trade-off between
uh fast notebook opening and fast
scrolling
um so you know the current
implementation i'm not going to
defend things it's absolutely ideal and
i can imagine better technologies but
the
but the current implementation uh gives
you
much faster initial opening of the
notebook but it does so by deferring
a lot of the work for uh
you know assembling the pieces of the
file that you haven't seen yet
and that work then gets done as you're
scrolling
so i don't understand something i mean
this is an issue that we've also had in
the cloud big time for multiple years
and it's finally
getting well solved and
you know things like uh caches
visual caches that aren't yet active
well and
in fact the cloud does have this problem
for a file that has never been
opened in the cloud i mean if you upload
it correct yes which has never had
caches made
yeah i mean that
but i guess my question is why aren't we
once you've opened a file why aren't we
asynchronously in the background
um doing those things to prep the rest
of the file
um the uh
uh well i mean the asynchronous
is not as easy as you can imagine
without
potentially introducing other kinds of
performance hiccups
um uh i understand i mean that's a
question of the scheduler for the
operating system and other such things
yeah yeah uh and
so you know
i have uh you know i have plans for this
but it's
it you know it's infrastructure work
that's uh
that requires time and dedication
right fair enough okay a few more
comments here and then let's go back to
our main thread
um sander
the fact that no glyph is available
isn't our fault
yes well fine but it's still
annoying and wow
as i have been known to say about some
bug reports we receive
you know we get bug reports that i will
say they're not our
faults but they are our problem because
people will ascribe it as our problem
even if
even if the bug had you know wasn't
caused by us in any way
um right for example i i
you know i routinely get bug reports on
and and just a month ago got a bug
report on this again
on you know you copy and paste uh uh
you know stuff into uh into
thunderbird uh and thunderbird renders
your code
using uh you know using emojis you know
it thinks the
colon greater than is uh you know some
kind of weird smiley or something
yeah and that's literally like that you
throw up your hands that there's
nothing we can do literally nothing we
can do about that
yeah yeah well is there really actually
nothing i mean we could yeah
well thunderbird that's about the best
we could do
yeah i mean we could copy every rule
delayed as full form
you know uh and make everyone suffer but
uh
yeah so there are you know these are the
kinds of
compromises that we sometimes have to
make
and uh you know in a case like that i
mean you know the
the full form rule delayed compromise is
so ridiculous that i would never
consider it i tell
most people to fix it but other cases
sometimes we do have to compromise a bit
um
okay so uh steve is commenting
if you're doing things like laser
cutting you want the pdf to be exact
in terms of measurements now
i would have thought that that was
something that we're handling well
in export for uh
oh my gosh i've forgotten the 3d stl for
example i mean we can specify precise
lengths and things like stl isn't that
correct
shoddy roger no i don't think so
stl i don't think has any notion of
units or
maybe it doesn't okay but i mean what
which should be using but
you scale them because uh and we do a
bunch of things for you to compute
like like if you're going to print it in
gold you know like
you know you you you might want to
hollow it out for instance and
you might okay but the question what
steve is pointing out here
when there is a format that has absolute
units
that there should be a way to specify
the absolute units in our system and
have the export work correctly
so i guess the question is for which
formats are there absolute units
you know pdf presumably uses points as
its unit system
i don't know what else uses unit system
i mean does svg have a unit system i
rather doubt it
does anybody know i don't know
yeah i don't know it wouldn't surprise
me though because it's very close to pdf
right but okay so that will be a thing
charlie this is a good point
we we should learn whether you know for
which export formats there are absolute
units does that make sense shoddy
yes given that we have a you know a big
unit system
there's no reason we can't support an
absolute units
notion so one thing that comes up with
pdf
and maybe this is the nub of
some of steve's complaints is that uh
because pdf is you know traditionally
a you know a printing or a you know uh
a paper-based format when we export to
pdf
by default we use the printing
environment and the printing environment
uh has uh you know
for standard plots it's
going to shrink things uh you know
by to like 80 or whatever it is
right actually steve is making a
different point which is saying that
that rather than specifying the overall
size
he would like to say user units
are millimeters
do you understand what i'm saying so one
unit of user space
let's say is one millimeter so for
example when we make
a plot we can absolutely make a plot
right now
plot as opposed to graphics we can make
a plot where the units
are where it has units and where the
axes will be labeled with those units
making sense so for example we could say
you know the depth of the ocean or
something
and as a function of position or
whatever and we can say it's x number of
miles
at this position or something or the the
um i don't know
you know the path of a submarine it went
down
x number of meters or whatever in the
ocean
and we've got those data points and
their time and
distance in actual units when we plot
them
in our system right list plot we'll plot
them according to the coordinate values
and then label the axes right guys roger
that's how it works right
yes okay but the graphics is completely
unaware of it
i'm aware yes right and of course
if you say now render this you know at
that size
and the units were miles and hours
you know it's absurd right that's not
useful but what i think steve is asking
for
is a mechanism within the graphics
within some kind of graphics-like thing
to have graphics with units which we
could perfectly well do
i mean in other words we don't have that
functionality right now the interesting
function repository item
to have something as a test where we
have graphics
where the coordinates are given as
united quantities
and where there is an evaluation
function which takes that graphics with
united quantities
and turns it into something that has for
example
an image size in points as which is
you know in other words you're turning
it from the thing that has
units to a thing that has doesn't have
explicit units in the in the coordinates
but has an overall size
specified for now yeah and and uh
i mean you know i think this could in
principle be done
with the current technology but you have
to you have to know to do some things
like you know
shutting down uh various sorts of
paddings and
and margins and that kind of thing that
can that can mess you up
um right but i think that would be
interesting i mean
for shoddy maybe somebody could try to
make
uh a prototype of that because it is a
good
general you know it's a good thing to
generally be able to do it wouldn't be
ordinary graphics right it would be
something like absolute graphics
because ordinary graphics you don't want
you know if if the thing is representing
mountains a mile high you don't want to
try to render that when you put it send
it to a printer
for example am i making sense
it makes sense i understand it i'm not
sure if we are going to be
better geared to do that or someone else
in either graphics team or
john's team well it's not for john
not not yet look i mean absolute
graphics
if we had such a thing would be a
a thing that evaluates absolute graphics
would evaluate to an ordinary graphics
for the time being
am i making sense
well and and and it would do things like
set plot range padding to none and
image padding to none and so on um
you know so that you're so that your
image size
has a predictable correspondence to
uh to the coordinates inside i kind of
like this idea
i think this would be quite useful for
many purposes
um i mean perhaps absolute graphics even
when you don't specify units
could at least do this thing of you know
switch off all padding etc etc etc
i mean switching off padding is a
dangerous business because you know you
end up with
lines getting sliced in two at the
margins and stuff like this
yeah yeah um but it is what it is
uh okay well anyway that that's a
um it will be a good thing to prototype
is that something for brexit turning off
line caps too
that would be another thing you wouldn't
want line caps in this sort of world
right uh and yes i think this is
probably a good match for the viz team
yep fine i agree okay
um you guys just want to get rid of it
yeah i mean shoddy and i are happy to
agree you just want to get rid of it
i think i think the prototype is not
it's not a valuable thing
i just think it's a waste time wasting
thing
oh really i don't think so why do you
think that
i mean this is the thing certainly i've
marked a bunch of times
well i've run into it a bunch of times
trying to make
you know precise graphics that fits into
you know published things for example
okay so we have a customer of one that
won't even pay us
um i think you're wrong
but maybe this isn't the right place to
discuss that right
let's get it built if i mean
i think we should get a prototype built
by somebody who can build it for the
function repository
right
all right
i mean i you know i think i think a you
know something that could be
built for the function repository that
probably wouldn't involve
a large amount of work is something
where you just assume
all the coordinates are points and then
you know you
shut down all the things which will
break that
you know uh that correlation i i i think
that
that's not what stephen asked for
stephen wanted units
yes steven's asking for something much
more general but if if you want to start
that's fine that's like the kind of
thing that could be built in a few hours
right that's what i'm asking for
initially to have units there
really all that has to happen is a
single map all
that goes in and finds all the leaves
and
you know changes every unit with unit
convert to points
right that's all that's needed it's one
line of code oh great
let's do it well let's do you want me to
write it right now i mean i
don't understand yeah why why is there
any problem with it i don't understand
this this is the kind of thing where we
can't
like you know explain to me why this is
not what i'm saying it is
well we'll implement it exactly like
that and then we'll ship it
no roger one lineup i want to understand
why that isn't what we're talking about
here there may be some trickiness but i
think that's basically what we're
talking about
i've never seen a project succeed like
that uh
roger yes let's understand why it isn't
that
i don't know i would have to go through
every primitive and directive in the
language in the graphics language
yeah every primitive and directive in
the graphics language that's right
that's right but but you know in so far
as they have so
so so the question is do i know every
option
and setting no but but argument for when
we've gotten interactive
in a first approximation no you said we
can ship it with the map
all right
look this is the this is kind of silly i
mean this is the kind of thing
where okay
let's get a prototype built and perhaps
it will work easily perhaps it won't
work easily
the kind of thing that we need for the
function repository is not the kind of
thing we need for the system
let's see if it works it may turn out
that there's some problem that makes it
quite useless
i don't know
and i'm gonna have to go in a couple of
minutes here unfortunately
um
okay we at least have two people
on our live stream saying that they've
run into exactly this issue
and ended up having to use other
products instead of ours because we
don't have a solution to this
of getting the correct size out well at
the level of not having units inside
that's easy to do
of saying assuming points and turning
off all the padding and
that's not a problem right i think
that's what we i think that's the main
thing
but this is a luxury being able to
specify units
as you know in terms of centimeters and
so on i think that's a luxury
the thing that isn't a luxury is being
able to map
through uh you know literal points
and having that work um
by the way this is more or less how
units would work in the front end is the
the front end
you know at the core will still assume
points for everything
but you know when given uh you know
a quantity in some other unit it will
just resolve with the points
yes i mean that's what i would assume
yeah
all right we unfortunately run out of
time here because i have
uh something can we say anything about
what direction we should go in the
future i i
i mean we i think we need to kind of
find a tangent here
and i it was a useful tangent however i
mean
i think the main issue here the main big
picture is
the workflow for taking unfortunately we
went off on graphics which we perhaps
shouldn't have done although it was
interesting
um you know the main issue is the
workflow
for taking code and what i thought we
were going to mostly discuss is the
formatting of code
the options for formatting code do you
switch off
you know syntax coloring do you not what
font
families are you you know what are you
doing elegant code or not
we had some people in this meeting who
haven't spoken up but who had hoped you
know would have
positive contributions to that
to the question of okay but i mean in
the end yes to those sorts of questions
yeah right but so for example one thing
i want to make sure of is that
when you export uh a piece of code in
tech
that the tech you get out is civilized
am i making sense is that is that
difficult to achieve i don't know
looking at machines yes that's what i
mean as a
tech that is civilized enough that one
could imagine somebody would
edit it in its destination form
okay so another issue is okay so another
issue
which is i think important is which i
don't know
how we should um okay so here another
issue
is including metadata um
in exported tech to be able to
reconstruct
you know to reconstruct code you
understand what i'm saying
yes i'm not sure how to do it in tech
but we do
actually do that in some other formats
right so again that's part of the the
story of what we should be exporting
you know their comments and texts so we
just put it in a comment i would assume
you have to have some kind of tagged
comment you you risk going
against that quote appearing machine
generated
right i was just gonna say it's like
this is
but the thing is that again
is a story of uh you know
there are multiple things it's like you
know include in a comment
include you know meta data tagging
um for round tripping
uh not the right words but you mean as
an export option
right yes well and you know i mean
something export and copy as something
that you and i i
i think are going to butt heads on is
you know that
when you have too many options you make
the whole system i i know i i don't
disagree
i don't disagree i think the default
should be to include the metadata
but you should be able to set it so that
it doesn't
yeah and and that's where you know it
you know
we want to figure out the happy path
workflows i agree
and i think it's going to be a raft that
has a limited
set of options there and where you can
bank switch it somewhere in some
preferences setting how do we benchmark
that we're doing well on this
because that's been a lot of things have
been attempted before and then it turned
out that it sort of doesn't actually
work because we don't really test it
type that's a really good question well
i think we need to use it ourselves
was to convert the last paper i worked
on
yeah pain level between one and ten
right that's a good start it'll average
out to be like 11 or 12 but okay
right no but i think that what what i'm
trying to i mean i'm i
i don't have an immediate solution but i
think we should try to define
sort of a test or a benchmark something
that defines yes but i think that's the
kind of
fine example is there are documents
without them
i agree i agree but i mean this is
danny has examples we have examples in
the physics project where we're going to
tech
you know i have plenty of examples where
we're going to
you know uh the where we're going to
essentially wordpress
and and um blog formats and so on
um although given the complexity of
those documents they really should be
fully notebooks because that's how
they're sourced but that hasn't hasn't
been how they've been deployed
traditionally
uh but yes i mean we should use it
ourselves that's the main test
i think you know we should also document
what you know if you write down a
workflow and you document it and the
thing i've got to go
but but um and and the thing is like
horrendously complicated to explain
then you lose agreed
right so you know i think that the um
i i just want to say that this this
question of what
uh you know there are other alternatives
other than including the metadata right
there
another alternative would be
you know include a pointer to a cloud
object for example
that's another way that you can which is
effectively what's being done in
my blog post type stuff
right uh anyway
particularly for the prerequisites okay
so
next time we need to follow up on this
um i think we probably need an hour and
a half to uh
uh to take a more serious bite here and
i've got to go
so see you guys